got beautiful blue skies and we weren't
sure if mother nature was going to put
on a barbecue
and fireworks or just a barbecue and it
looks like
we're going to have plenty of blue sky
in the valley and lots of heat but now
up in the mountains it's going to be a
little bit different we're going to
check that forecast
the lakes is down to 79 degrees aleante
down to 78
pretty much everybody else is in the 80s
this morning and you can tell the air
is drier we've dried out a lot since
yesterday so it's warm but at least it's
not warm and sticky 107 today a little
bit hotter than yesterday's 106
uv index of 11. that means you can burn
very quickly if you don't have good
sunscreen on
of 30 plus spf so please take care of
yourself the kiddos
we've got a cold front stretched out
from the southern plains to the
northeast where they're going to get a
lot of rain
and it is going to be a soggy start to
their july 4th weekend
hurricane elsa is a category one
hurricane
on track to make its way through the
caribbean through the weekend
and right up to southern florida by
early next week tuesday night into
wednesday
staying a very strong storm and you know
they are still
of course cleaning up that collapsed
condo and they don't need to worry about
a tropical storm there but it looks like
they're going to have to deal with some
bad weather
more heat for the northwest over 500
deaths caused
by that intense heat high pressure for
the most part will cap
off the thunderstorms into the weekend
but the higher elevations tomorrow here
at home
mount charleston has a chance for
thunderstorms tomorrow 108
out at the lake today oh it's going to
be a hot weekend please
stay safe out there could get some gusty
outflow winds from arizona thunderstorms
102 for sunday evening at 8 o'clock
a lot of fireworks going off and the
winds will stay light enough for all the
fireworks to go off rooftops it looks
like it's going to be great
but we are going to have a warm weekend
next week downright
extra hot again 110 plus by thursday